bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france les tractations
sont donc en cours en allemagne en vue
de la formation du gouvernement à quelle
alliance est ce que vous vous attendez
alors si vous permettez avant de parler
des alliances il faut revenir bas mot
sur les faits marquants ce scrutin qui
était marqué par une forte participation
et le premier fait marquant qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est quand même la claque
jambes et une gigantesque monumental
qu'a subies le parti de la chancelière
les chrétiens-démocrates et quand même
un désaveu de la politique qui a été
menée ces derniers temps puisque le lac
ces vélos obtient son pire résultat de
son histoire avec des personnalités
importantes de ce parti sont battus dans
leurs circonscriptions
et la deuxième chose qu'on peut
remarquer c'est que effectivement le
parti social-démocrate progresse de 5
points c'est quand même une progression
par défaut d'une certaine manière
puisque le le vice-chancelier actuelles
relations ce qui prive la poste le poste
de chancelier pour succéder à la madame
angela merkel
il n'a pas
n'a pas remis en cause un certain nombre
de choses notamment le pacte de
stabilité j'y reviendrai et se situer
dans une certaine continuité par rapport
à la politique est menée même s'il a
promis un certain nombre d'éléments plus
sociaux la dernière chose que je voulais
signaler en matière de résultats ce sont
les verts alors l'univers progresse
certes aussi d'un peu plus de 5 points
comme on en a le plus haut historique
mais sans n'ont pas caché qu'ils étaient
le même extrêmement déçu de ce résultat
je rappelle quand même qu'en avril il
était crédité de 28% des suffrages et
qu'ils avaient rêvé d'accéder à la
chancellerie
alors ça n'a pas été le cas
j'ajoute que dans les élections agir
dans les caves et ludovic ont eu lieu
également à berlin c'est dans un autre
le land de mecklembourg poméranie
à berlin les verts se retrouvent
derrière le spd alors qu'ils étaient il
avait l'ambition de gouverner la ville
de berlin donc il y a d'une certaine
manière n'y a pas eu de vague verte et
pour ce qui le concerne l'avenir vie la
mort la question des alliances va se
poser et va se poser pendant pas mal de
moi en tout cas plusieurs semaines et
probablement quelques mois
on peut pour l'instant spéculer mais
c'est le résultat qui compte pour
l'instant que vous expliquer cette
défaite historique de l'accès des où
l'accès des eaux a besoin de renouveau
c'est ce qu'a admis son président et
candidat à la chancellerie hermine
achète le problème c'est le parti ou
bien son candidat
écoutez il est vrai que c'était la
première fois depuis très longtemps
qu'il n'y avait pas de chancelier
sortant puisque idées-là merkel avait
indiqué il ya déjà trois ans près de
trois ans qu'elle ne se représenterait
pas d'ailleurs il était en difficulté
politique à ce moment là et c'est pour
ça qu'elle a préféré passer la main a
annoncé qu'elle passerait la main les
difficultés d'accéder ou etienne
d'allusions du pouvoir est une politique
qui a été menée et qui a été menée
contre l'intérêt d'une majorité du pays
enfin sur le plan social les reculs
sociaux on était quand même important il
ya eu des
mécontentements qui s'est également
exercé compte tenu de la pandémie et de
la manière dont les couleurs de nos
idées a fait face bref madame merkel
était depuis 16 ans au pouvoir depuis
huit ans dans le cadre d'une grande
coalition je crois que c'est ça qui
était désavoué au national au leader des
sociaux démocrates a déclaré que la cd
ou devait aller dans l'opposition après
être arrivé en deuxième position il n'y
aura donc pas voulu de grande coalition
selon vous à quel futur politique
allemande est ce que vous vous attendez
alors je devrai bien on va on va faire
quelques hypothèses sur les coalitions
s'il ya du suspense sur la nature et sur
la composition de la future coalition et
sur le nom du prochain chancelier il ya
beaucoup moins de suspense sur la
politique que le prochain gouvernement
mènera je rappelle que les quatre
principaux partis sont tous fidèles à
l'intégration européenne et même si ils
ont été extrêmement discret dans la
campagne ce sont des questions qu'on
était quasiment par les loquets il se
situe dans un cadre contraint les
seconds l'union européenne et donc il
n'y a pas de mystère le pacte de
stabilité restera l'allemagne continuera
à le défendre et les principales
contraintes seront respectés et donc il
n'y a pas de grand suspense il y aura
pas de changement d'orientation
profondément alors
le parti social-démocrate
évidemment aspirent à le désigner le
prochain chancelier donc olaf scholz
faut se rappeler qu'il ya encore
quelques mois il était donné à 15% même
un sondage et personne n'aurait parié un
kopeck sur son accès à la chancellerie
les choses se sont retournés il a
l'impression d'une sorte de résurrection
mais fondamentalement ça ne changera pas
ça ne changera pas la donne alors il ya
deux coalitions aujourd'hui que les que
les commentateurs évoquent parmi les
plus probables soient dirigés
effectivement par les sociaux-démocrates
et qui associe les deux partenaires
mineurs en quelque sorte que sont les
verts et les libéraux soit la même
coalition mais avec comme à la tête les
chrétiens-démocrates également de re cac
qui s'associerait avec les avec les
verts et les libéraux dans les deux cas
ça paraît contradictoire en réalité
fondamentalement les la politique qui
sera menée ne sera pas différente et
donc de ce point de vue là ce qui
attendrait un changement majeur en
allemagne
seront déçus j'ajoute peut-être comme
élément il ya deux parties dont nous
n'avons pas parlé qui sont alors qu'ils
sont deux extrêmes de l'échiquier
politique il ya le parti die linke qui a
obtenu un sport un score historiquement
bas qui diminue de moitié son score et
passe en tout 5 % probablement parce
qu'il a tenté d'imiter les verts ce qui
était tout à fait à l'encontre de son
propre électorat traditionnel qui a été
hachée vos questions sociales notamment
à l'est et puis il y à l'afd souvent
décrit comme populistes et qui a certes
reculé 2 % de deux points mais qui reste
avec un score à deux chiffres et ses
dirigeants ont souligné hier que ont
rappelé hier qu'il ya quatre ans quand
il avait fait 1-1 score de plus de 12%
quelques mois seulement après sa
création
encouragé en cela par la crise
migratoire tous les autres dirigeants
tous les autres partis avaient dire on
va virer la vie des du parlement la
prochaine fois donc qu'en 2021 c'est pas
ce qui est arrivé et je rappelle
simplement que le la lte et avait été le
seul parti à avoir cette précède
prononcés pour la sortie de l'allemagne
de l'union européenne alors c'est un
thème qu'il a choisi de ne pas aborder
pendant la campagne préférant se
concentrer sur les questions de pandémie
sur les questions sanitaires à tort ou à
raison c'est pas à moi de juger en tout
état de cause ceux qui attendaient une
élimination de la ld en sort aussi pour
leurs frais un tout dernier mot assez
rapidement si vous le voulez bien parce
que malheureusement le temps nous manque
quelles conséquences de cette période
d'incertitude en allemagne sur la scène
internationale pour l'europe et aussi
évidemment pour le couple franco
allemand alors que la france prendra me
rappelle la présidence tournante de lieu
en janvier
elle prendra la présidence tournante de
l'ue eux et en même temps ce sa mort
sera pour de bon la campagne électorale
en france et donc la période
d'incertitude d'incertitudes entre vie
mais en tout cas une certitude sur la
coalition et qui prévaut en allemand et
qui sera prolongée par l'incertitude en
france et 5 elle beaucoup bruxelles et
les commentateurs qui qui lui sont qui
lui sont fidèles en disant tout ça va
faire une période d'immobilisme je
rappelle en outre que l'allemagne
préside le g7 l'année prochaine donc oui
il y aura une période d'incertitude dire
à une période de de flottement et c'est
certainement pas une période où l'union
européenne pourra prendre des
initiatives majeures je m'en réjouis
pour ma part mais je le répète il faut
pas non plus exagérer cet état de choses
fondamentalement ce qui est en jeu c'est
le nom du chancelier c'est la
composition de la coalition mais pas
fondamentalement les orientations
politiques qui sont menées c'est
d'ailleurs un des thèmes et des éléments
qui nous vous expliquons 12 présentons
dans notre édition de notre mensuel
imprimés mensuel donc qui paraît dans
quelques jours écrit vos téléspectateurs
peuvent vous qu'on trouvait sur rupture
tirer presse pour les faire pour avoir
toutes les précisions un sport mais
voilà l'analyse de fond c'est clair du
suspense sur le nom du prochain
chancelier mais beaucoup moins sur la
politique qui va donner merci beaucoup
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne pierre
lévy est rédacteur en chef donc de
rupture